here we are once again finding a sea of
tears for me to wade through this time i
thought we should change it up a bit and
instead of reviewing just the smug
self-satisfied liberals who hate me i
thought we should see a pair of smug
self-satisfied libertarians who hate me
this is a brad and hannah as they're
known to the five people who followed
them and watched them they had a lot to
say so let's take a look now on the
complete opposite end of this spectrum
are arranged marriages instead of a
boundless never-ending buffet of options
a young person in a culture that
practices arranged marriages will be
assigned just one and they don't even
make the choice
their families just pair them up and say
here you go
there's far less freedom and far less
autonomy in a system of that sort but it
is without a doubt oh superior to our
system
we would be happier
every person that dating scene right now
would be happier if they were just
matched up with someone against their
will
against your will whoever that's a new
dating app right
here you go you're assigned this person
go make babies
what the heck is right i don't know how
is it conservative to be like yeah it
would have a lot less freedom and
individual rights but it'd be better
that's like that's not what conservatism
in america has ever been about how bad
is your marriage is what i want to know
that you think people should be like
assign people like a lottery system like
here you go and that would be just as
good as whatever you found i
it's a little rapey to be honest the
vibes of like yeah women should be
assigned to me as my wife
no they should not sir
they should not this seems like it comes
from a very insult kind of mindset of
like i can't get women on my own they
never pick me and she's just gonna find
me
i know but he speaks for that product
yeah i guess
yeah
just a quick tip for any future
libertarians react videos uh i would
dial down the music but also the
shrillness and smugness by about eight
or nine points because right now you're
at a full ten on the smarmy dork scale
and it's it's frankly a bit overwhelming
as mentioned libertarians in general
have a serious problem with smugness but
here i think we've met like the
libertarian smug
super spreaders these are patient zeros
of libertarian smugness they also have
zero in the way of arguments rebuttals
or clever comebacks
uh they are of course being wildly
dishonest about my argument i never said
that arranged marriages are ideal i also
never said that women should be assigned
to me to be married i also never
mentioned that women should be the only
ones subjected to it um i said that
arranged marriages are better than our
current approach to dating that's simply
because our current approach couldn't
possibly be any worse
but is there at least some wisdom to the
arranged marriage model yes there is and
before you continue scoffing and gasping
at the very idea that there could be
anything redeeming in it consider that
many cultures around the world
especially non-western cultures have had
and still have such a system
are they all just a bunch of idiot
troglodytes brad and hannah
are you sure you want to make that
argument
if that's the broad brush you want to
use to paint billions of people and
dozens of culture cultures across the
world and throughout history
go for it i guess fits with the whole
smug theme i guess
as for me my preferred system is
essentially the one we had in this
country before the modern dating scene
began to form and certainly before
hookup culture and dating apps took hold
i favor courtship where the dating phase
is understood by all parties concerned
to be the path to marriage
typically in a courtship culture
families
may not choose your spouse but they are
heavily involved in selecting potential
matches this is far superior to our
current arrangement where a legion of
confused lethargic hapless
single people scroll endlessly through
avatars on their phones randomly
selecting one after another for fleeting
temporary flings or emotion infatuation
and physical attraction are the only
driving forces the only litmus test one
time my dad tried to set me up with
somebody and i was aghast at who he
thought i would like i was actually
insulted i was like dad you know i'm
cute right like
you know like i don't have a problem
pulling men right like
no
absolutely that was a suggestion it
wasn't a it was just what he would like
me to be with which was like this super
christian guy who was in his church and
who like was slightly balding but like
he thought was a good option for me
seems like a really good guy and i was
like yeah i'm gonna need a really good
guy who's not balding like and also who
doesn't live in anderson south carolina
because i'm for sure as hell not and
like you know those kinds of things so
all i'm saying is i would never i love
my parents dearly but i would never want
them to pick my mate they would they
would have no clue how to begin to pick
who i would actually want yeah no it's
just creepy uh and it's really crazy and
i just can't relate to that one at all
can someone make a video attacking me
that's that like put some effort into it
i'm looking for a good challenge here
this is just
so your your dad set you up with someone
who you admit is a really good guy but
he's losing his hair so you had no
interest in him and you say that you're
too attractive to be wasting your time
with men who have the audacity to
possess physical flaws now look i
wouldn't usually say what i'm about to
say but speaking to the to the girl now
you earlier felt comfortable commenting
on my marriage inaccurately of course so
you've opened yourself up to some harsh
truths and here it is cupcake
you may be slightly overestimating
yourself you you seem to have
erroneously given yourself a couple of
extra points on the one to ten physical
attractiveness scale
just just just a tip
and even if you hadn't if you're single
and making your decisions based on
hairlines you're either going to be
lonely and miserable as you are right
now for the rest of your life or
eventually you're going to be
frivolously marrying some scumbag who
isn't a good guy but at least still has
all his hair and a short time later
you're going to file for divorce and try
to make yourself into the victim of your
failed marriage when it's your own
vanity and stupidity that put you in
that position
one of those two results are your
destiny unless
you learn to look a little deeper in
your search for a mate
the fact that you can't look deeper
right now and that your father seems to
have a better view of who would be a
good match for you than you do only
proves my point
you yourself specifically would be
better off with an arranged marriage
now i'm not sure i could say the same
for the poor sap who ends up with you on
the altar but you would actually be
better off with that yeah usually i like
to give credit to uh libertarians for
having a little bit of intellect i mean
just really a little little bit but a
little bit um not a lot you can you can
also find a crumb of wisdom in there
babbling every once while unfortunately
brad and hannah disproved that point roe
v wade has been overturned and this
battle is now finally leaving dc and
going to the grassroots no group in
america is better positioned than 40
days for life to fight this battle their
1 million volunteers hold peaceful
vigils outside of abortion facilities in
a thousand different cities and in fact
most of their volunteers are located in
blue states which is good because that's
where they're going to be most needed
now of course many former abortion
facility directors say that these vigils
can cause the abortion no-show rate to
increase to as high as 75 which is a
major blow to the abortion business and
also means that you're saving lives
these peaceful vigils have even led to
many closures of abortion facilities in
america nearly half of which were in
cities like san francisco chicago and
seattle hardly pro-life areas 40 days
for life is effectively changing hearts
and minds in the grassroots to end
abortion check out their locations their
podcasts and their free magazine at
40daysforlife.com again for more
information on 40 days for life simply
head to
40daysforlife.com so let's move on to
jamie raines who's a trans youtuber who
uh let's just say
she has a whole other set of problems
listen from the daily wire which i think
i've heard of made by somebody or
involving heavily somebody called matt
walsh
[Music]
what is a woman immediately is he
wearing a sandwich board that says what
is a woman okay
can you tell me that
[Music]
oh you're at the women's march you must
have some idea please if one person can
tell me what a woman is you are not here
for women we ask you to leave what is
that what is that oh wow so a dude going
to a woman's march and going up to women
and asking them to define what a woman
is and probably acting like it's some
big gotcha moment yeah that's
interesting oh let's not forget the
sandwich board i mean what definition
was he looking for one based off of
genitals and reproductive organs that's
a little bit very narrow and not exactly
great to boil people down to their parts
okay well first of all jamie
how do you know i'm a dude i don't i
didn't tell you that that was not that
was not said
so where'd you get that from
and yeah it is a gotcha moment
in fact if people are marching in a
women's march and holding signs and
chanting slogans claiming that women are
under attack and being oppressed and yet
they have absolutely no idea what a
woman is and can't begin to define the
term then yes that's a gotcha moment as
it reveals the inherent absurdity and
incoherence of their worldview but it's
not a gotcha moment that i engineer
okay i'm not backing anybody into a
corner
all i did was
walk up to them and ask them what the
words they're using mean
that's a fair question in fact that's
the fairest question you can ever ask
anyone is when they're using words to
say what do you mean by that how could
that be an unfair question
if it becomes a gotcha moment for you
that only shows just how totally vapid
and ridiculous your ideology is as for
what kind of definition i'm looking for
well to start with i'd like a definition
some kind of definition
let's just get a definition on the table
first and then we can debate whether
it's the right or wrong one but you guys
won't put any definition at all on the
table
you act like the word has no meaning at
all like it's just a bunch of arbitrary
gibberish and yet you continue to use
the word
and uh and you and you expect us all to
know what it means or to know what you
mean when you use it so again is it a
gotcha yes it certainly is
but i didn't get you
you got yourself that medically
transitioned to appear like a male i
will never
be a man
oh
no abs no do not agree with that
99.9999999
nine percent of trans men will very
strongly disagree with that statement
don't know if that person actually
identifies as a trans man by the sounds
of it they are assigned female at birth
and transitioned in the sense of taking
testosterone and living within society
as a man but yes sure for the purposes
of your seemingly transphobic
documentary go and find one of the very
very few
trans people who holds these kind of
gender critical transphobic views on
trans people and include them ignore the
many thousands in the vast vast majority
of trans people who will very strongly
disagree with this very very small
number of trans people who will say
things like this
but who cares if scott nugent's views
are in the minority among trans people
trans people are in the minority among
the general population if you can
dismiss scott for being the minority
then can't i dismiss
you for being in the minority
also i did not ignore other trans people
we talked to lots of trans people in the
film some of whom you've already seen in
the trailer despite claiming that we
ignored them we tried to speak to many
more trans people but they refused to
speak to us and this is a pretty common
phenomenon right trans activists claim
that nobody will talk to us
oh why don't you talk to us and yet when
i try to talk to them they literally run
away
i mean literally get up and run away in
some cases yeah i think i know why jaime
is really mad and has nothing to do with
my opinions jamie has beard envy and
look it'll get you nowhere some of us
were born with this magnificent ability
and others make youtube videos about it
also you were born a woman so that might
not help either
you